- So, how did you land
the role on "Ted Lasso",
other than being perfect for it?
(all laugh)
- Well, thank you.
Well, I studied my Master
in Acting in the UK.
I saved money over there
and before going to the UK,
and then I was in Mexico
and I received the
audition for "Ted Lasso".
I did it, didn't hear anything.
They started shooting in August,
So I thought, "Well, nothing happened."
But then I received a random
tweet from Bill Lawrence,
a showrunner of the show who said, just,
"Good audition, man."
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] Really?
- And I was like, okay, either
he's playing with my feelings
or there's something good happening.
- Oh my God that'd be so mean.
So mean.
- Yeah.
And then I did more
auditions and story short,
I got the role for an Icelandic man.
So when I arrived on set,
I was called Gooner, and I was like,
"If I'm playing an Icelandic man,
I need more preparation."
- Wait, what?
So originally it wasn't even
the role you're in right now?
- No, no, no.
The role was for a guy from Iceland,
but they liked my audition,
from what I know now,
that they kept it and that's why
they adapted it to who I am and I got-
(applause drowns out sound)
- Oh my God,
I love it, you were so great.
(guest applaud)
That's amazing (giggles)!